well here we are without hope without a
future all is lost
the green New Deal was voted down in a
Senate the final tally was 0 to 57 not
one senator voted for this legislation
not a single one they all said they all
said oh no we'd rather we'd rather drown
the planets and so be it that's what's
gonna happen Alexandra okay co Cortez
has told us time and time again that if
we don't pass the green New Deal
we are all going to die and I believe
Alexander okay Sea of Cortez she would
not lie if she says it's true even if
it's factually wrong it's still morally
correct so even if we don't die
factually we're still gonna die morally
so what's the point anymore that's the
question I'm asking that what am I doing
here in this place what are you doing
watching this we it's over don't you get
it it's all over
everything's gonna die the caribou will
die first they they've are they're
already dying the polar bears are next
the Penguins will go no arc is going to
save them this time or us but the
difference is we deserve it we deserve
to die okay well I don't deserve it but
but you deserve it I've done my part I
I've made I tried to save the planet I
rode my bike to the post office last
week I reuse my hotel towels you know I
I when I pump my gas I shake my head
disapprovingly because I don't like
using the gas my watch is made from
reused wood okay I have made the
sacrifices it's you selfish pigs you're
the ones this is your fault this is all
your fault so what to do now well
there's nothing to do but wait for the
tribulation mother Gaia is going to
exact her vengeance on all of us and
there will be no survivors you are going
to die your family your children your
friends everyone you know will die in
agony soon
well anyway let me tell you about hair
club listen your confidence is important
confidence is one of the most important
things that you can have in life is if
you want to be successful in life it
doesn't help to be paranoid and insecure
take it from me and sometimes one change
can make all the difference
hair club knows this fact and they're
inviting you to become part of the hair
club fami to see how getting the most
out of your hair can change your life
they understand if you're you know
losing your hair if you're having issues
like that they understand the emotions
that you're feeling right now and they
know the questions that you have that's
why Hair Club is the leader in total
hair solutions with a legacy of success
for over 40 years they've been doing
this so whether you're looking to
revitalize the growth of your own hair
to learn more about the latest methods
for hair replacement restoration hair
clubs professionally trained stylists
hair health experts and consultants will
craft a solution that's very
personalized and that will work for use
this is not a cookie cutter kind of
thing this is specific for you so go to
hair club.com slash walsh today for a
free hair analysis that's free again and
a free take home hair kit all valued at
over 300 dollars but again you get that
for free all you have to do is go to
hair club.com slash walsh for a free
hair analysis and a free hair kit again
hair club comm slash walls take
advantage of the free stuff when it's
offered to you I don't know why you
wouldn't do it experience your hair and
your life at its best
only with hair club I'm certain you'll
love the club all right a reporter for
ABC I want to I want to talk a little
bit about Jesse small and I can spend a
lot of time on it but there are a lot of
other things to talk about including by
the way this is coming up in a few
minutes but the New York Times I guess
is trying to salvage its its reputation
after embarrassing itself many times
over especially with the Moller
investigation and so the way they're
doing that is they figure they're gonna
try to disprove God and so we're going
to we're going to take a look and see if
they succeeded in disproving God but
first let's talk about Jesse Smollett a
reporter for ABC Terry Moran
says on Twitter is what he tweeted he
said cook counties cook cook cook County
Clerk's office that's a tongue twister
tells ABC they were shocked that no
written motions were filed with the
court in connection with today's
surprising dismissal 'no smollett case
on top of that the case has been wiped
off their database as if it never
existed so they've already wiped it off
and they didn't file any motions or
anything like that nothing was written
down they just said hey you can go and
they erased it like it never occurred
meanwhile Joe maggots or my guy I guess
I should figure out how to pronounce
this guy can't really be maggots can it
that would be a really unfortunate last
name that's the assistant state's
attorney who ostensibly made the
decision to drop the charges against
Millette yesterday although we know
really it came from his boss who's kim
fox who had originally recused herself
from the case because of her
associations with the family but then
she decided you know never mind I think
I'll get involved he was interviewed by
a CNN affiliate yesterday and his
comments are interesting this is what he
said he said this was not an exoneration
to say he was exonerated by us or anyone
else is not true we believe he did
listen to this part okay we believe he
did what he was charged with doing so
the people who dropped the charges are
convinced of his guilt they just said
yeah he did it this was never about his
innocence and smollett obviously knows
that by the way which shines a different
light on his comments that he made
outside of the courthouse you may
remember yesterday he gave that chomp
and press conference and let's let's
watch those comments again
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother's son if I was capable
of one drop of what I was accused of
this has been an incredibly difficult
time honestly one of the worst of my
entire life
but I'm a man of faith and I'm a man
that has knowledge of my history and I
would not bring my family our lives were
the movement who a fire like this
I just wouldn't so he's playing it up
like he's been vindicated
right he's he's celebrating like this
was you know like he'd been proven
innocent or something like that when he
knows that that's not the case so the
guy is is a pathological liar and a
sociopath he's such a pathological liar
that even I'm sure even the Clintons are
looking at this guy and they're
impressed with the way with it with with
just it's hard for me to even say that
he's a good liar because you can tell
that he's acting but he obviously has no
qualms about lying he has no issues with
it so what we have here is a guilty man
who everybody knows is guilty who even
his allies the state's attorney's office
and that's a problem that he has allies
everybody does even as even as allies at
the state's attorney's office they say
that he's guilty and yet he's being
allowed to go free with his record wiped
clean because he's rich famous and
connected and that's not my
interpretation of what's going on that
is just what's happening clear as day
for all to see and really this is what
gets me about it and this is why I think
it's so important it's the the blatant
nature of this corruption is what makes
it all the more harmful so it's one
thing if you've got these kind of
corrupt deals that are hashed out behind
closed doors and dimly lit smoky rooms
and that kind of thing we all know that
that stuff happens and it's not good I'm
not saying that it's good or it's you
know it's it's okay because they do it
secretly but I think when it goes down
in broad daylight and the corruption is
flaunted in our faces then I think that
makes it all the more corrosive to our
system and to and especially into the to
the public's confidence in the system
because now we're being told to just
simply accept that we have a two-tier
justice system and some people are more
equal than others and that's the way it
is and they're simply putting it out
there for us to see and say yeah it's
one thing for us to have theories that
it works this way or that a corrupt deal
was made it's another thing when the
corrupt deal makers are out in public
basically saying yeah that's the way it
goes that's what's going on here what of
it
what are you gonna do about it and I
think as far as what needs to be done
about it I think Trump needs to get the
DOJ involved because this is now this
isn't simply a guy faking a hate crime
which is bad enough already when you
hear something like well he was just a
false police report well that's a crime
that can vary in in terms of its degree
of severity depending on the situation
and when you're faking a hate crime and
you're famous and you're putting it out
there for everyone to see that is a
really really serious crime but on top
of that now we have corruption in
government so I think the DOJ needs to
get involved one other point about this
before we move on you know the the
you're hearing a lot of people media try
to op the scape and get around what they
know to be just straightforward
corruption and injustice and they're
trying to get around it by saying ah
geez such a such a complicated weird
crazy thing I don't know what to think
about it nobody knows what to think I
guess we'll never know what happened and
then they just want to move on no it's
it's it's not confusing it is weird in
many ways but it's not confusing we all
do know what to think of it it's
extremely clear to all of us so that's
not good enough
in fact Camilla Harris I don't have a
clip but Camille Harris was interviewed
on I believe it was CNN one of the news
channels yesterday and she was asked
about this remember that Camille Harris
when this first happened when Smollett
first faked the the hate crime
Camille Harris immediately said
that came out and she knew exactly what
happened and she condemned it and said
this is as I believe she called it a
modern day lynching and all of that well
now she's gotten tongue-tied and she was
asked about it last night and she said
oh I don't know I'm at a loss for words
who knows what to say about this it's
all just so confusing no again it's not
confusing listen to what the state's
attorney's office is saying they're
saying yes he did it we're just letting
him go what are you confused about
Camille Harris what's confusing about
that speaking of double standards I want
to I got to tell you about this car DB
as you probably know is a very famous
very successful for some reason female
rapper and she's not only successful in
rap she has in this is a mainstream
thing she has endorsements from Pepsi
and other companies well an Instagram
video that she recorded about three
years ago resurfaced over the weekend
and now I have said that I think that
there should be a statute of limitations
on getting outraged over public
statements people made about you know
people made years ago and things that
they posted online years ago digging up
old posts to nail someone is usually a
lame move and I and I don't like it so
when you start a sentence with Oh an old
Instagram video was was resurfaced
normally I'm gonna say yeah who cares
let's let's move on but it's kind of a
different ball game entirely if the old
post that we're talking about consists
of the person admitting to violent crime
well then I think it's different if this
was just a something that they wrote and
it was offensive that's one thing but in
this video only three years old
cardi B admits actually brags really
that she used to lure men back to her
hotel rooms and drugged them and robbed
them okay she she it made this in front
of everyone the funny thing is it's not
really funny but the sort of funny thing
is is that
she admits she admits this in in the
context of defending herself so this was
evidence that she brought to the
forefront to defend herself now I wish I
could play the clip but it's it's every
other word is the f-bomb and you
wouldn't be able to understand it
between all the bleeping but she cites
this fact about herself that she used to
lure men from the strip club back to her
back to hotel room drugged and robbed
them she cites this in order to prove
that she deserves her success so she's
getting very emotional in the video ends
and and she says oh some people say I
don't deserve my success oh yeah well I
used to drug people and robbed them what
no you see cardi B that that that only
further proves that you don't deserve
your success you were you were what a
stripper slash robber and then and now
you're a millionaire no that doesn't
that doesn't help at all that that makes
it even worse by the way cardi B is 26
years old and she made this video I
guess when she was 23 so she's talking
about things that she must have done
back what like in in what 2011 or 2010
assuming that she was at least 18 years
old or so if she was a stripper at the
time when she was doing this the point
is it's not like this is someone who's
65 and admitting to doing something
forty years ago in that case even if
it's well if it's robbery that it still
matters but I don't know forty years is
a long time I so you could at least buy
the the argument that they've changed
significantly in the mean time but if
you're talking about you're 26 years old
and you're saying oh back in my youth
this is what I did okay but that was
like yesterday so that doesn't really
they're not much of a time difference
there
after this video surfaced cardi B came
out with a statement if you can call it
that and and it falls well short of an
apology I'll read a little bit of it as
best I can
she says I'm seeing on social media that
alive I did alive
video I did three years ago has popped
back up alive where I talked about
things I had to do in my past right or
wrong but I felt I needed to do to make
a living I never claimed to be perfect I
mean some people the things they had to
do to make a living would include maybe
landscaping working at Burger King no
she had to lure men back to her hotel
room and and rob them is what she had to
do I never claimed to be perfect or come
from a perfect world with a perfect past
I always speak my truth I always own my
s I want to say it's good that she owns
her ass her that's certainly wouldn't
want anyone else to have to own it but
and no one is saying cardi B that you
have to be perfect I'm not perfect
you're right then nobody on the planet
right now is perfect but maybe don't
drug and Rob people you know I feel like
there's a lot of room between perfect
and drugging and robbing people you've
got just a lot of area in between and so
I I feel like maybe you should try to
land somewhere in that in-between area
so it doesn't do much good if someone
says oh it's terrible that you drugged
and robbed people well hey man I'm not
perfect okay she says I made the choices
I did at the time because I had very
limited options I was blessed to have
been able to rise from that but so many
women have not so many women are still
drugging and robbing men whether or not
they were poor choices at the time I did
what I had to do to survive
so she's not even admitting that they
were poor choices she was saying well
whether or not they were poor choices I
for the sake of argument let's say there
were poor choices but it's what I had to
do the men I spoke about in my in my
life were men that I dated that I was
involved with men that were conscious
willing and aware I have a pass that we
can't change I guess I should have what
so the men that she drugged and robbed
she she was dating and they were
conscious will
so they were willing to be drugged and
robbed so that she got consent first I
guess that would change things a little
bit if I believed it so she said listen
I my plan here is just you know to drug
you and rob you do I have your consent
oh yeah absolutely
I'm not sure I really buy that a lot of
the comments on Instagram are supportive
I'll read you a few the comments
supporting her love you mommy your truth
is all good ass well I can't even read
these don't owe nobody no MF explanation
of whatever you had to do to survive
someone else says you ain't gotta
explain s - nobody boo ethe these people
oh man
people are so stupid in this world I
can't even this is just in illegible
okay anyway let's just suffice it to say
there are a lot of supportive comments
as far as I can tell they're supportive
I don't know I don't know
now let me ask you this is the question
I said double standards right is there
any chance is there any chance in hell
that a man could admit that he drugged
and robbed women and he would still have
a career after that is there any chance
of that now I think especially a rapper
could admit to drugging and robbing men
a male rapper could probably probably
make that admission and and be okay so
that the double standard here is is that
the fact that it this is okay not even
so much because cardi B is a woman but
because of who she was drugging and
robbing and that's that makes it even
more perverse doesn't it basically our
society is saying you know they were
guys they probably deserved it they were
conscious willing and aware sure we'll
go with that this is this is absolutely
crazy
and she hasn't even apologized for it
so it's not even as though she's saying
I this thing I did was horrible
I'm utterly ashamed of it it's a
terrible thing I'm so so sorry I have
changed she's not even saying that she's
saying that's what I had to do which
seems to insinuate if she fell on hard
times again if she lost her record deal
well watch out fellas because she might
be coming for you again also now I don't
know how the statute of limitations
works exactly with this but she is
admitting to a series of felony crimes
so wouldn't the police have something to
say about that I don't know all right
moving on it this is interesting
Peter Atherton is allegedly a professor
of philosophy he wrote an article for
the New York Times titled
a god problem perfect all-powerful
all-knowing the idea of the deity most
Westerners Westerners accept is actually
not coherent so this as I said appeared
in The New York Times couple days ago
trying to disprove the existence of God
and this guy is he's writing quite a
check with that headline he's setting
the expectation that he will essentially
disprove God by demonstrating that the
very idea of God is logically impossible
that's what he's that's what he's
claiming is gonna do now I will say that
this is probably the you know I would
say this is probably the best available
tactic for an atheist if they want to
disprove God and most atheists will will
say that they don't have to disprove the
existence of God because the burden of
proof isn't on them but in spite of that
burden of proof kind of deflection the
fact is most of them do think that they
can prove that God doesn't exist and
they make arguments all the time that
they believe do essentially prove
the non-existence of God but the problem
is if you want to go that route
there are several moves that you can't
make but you can't get into science
ok science cannot disprove God because
science can only show us the workings of
the natural world that's all that
science can do in science is a very
important thing for that reason because
we live in the natural world but science
cannot tell us anything about what lies
beyond it so even if you think it's
absurd to suggest that something lies
beyond the natural world regardless that
is the claim that we theists are making
that there is something beyond it and
science simply cannot penetrate beyond
you know the limitations of the natural
world so that doesn't work
anthropology history sociology all of
these avenues are a are avenues that
atheists will use to try to attack
religion and belief in God but none of
it can do the trick
now logic is a different matter though
because God doesn't have to obey the
laws of science as we know them but he
does have to be logically coherent
existence if we're going to say that
anything exists in any sense at all then
that thing must be logically coherent
logically incoherent logically
contradictory things by definition
cannot exist so if God is like a married
bachelor or a square circle then he
can't exist literally can't it would be
a contradiction to things that negate
each other cannot exist at the same time
simultaneously so the question is is God
a married bachelor
is he a square skirt circle that's what
the professor claims he's going to prove
does he succeed well let's go through
this I'm gonna go through this bit by
bit I'll read all of his arguments such
as they are and and then I'll respond
I'm not gonna read his entire article
I'll just skip to the parts that are
actually arguments so he said
let's first consider the attribute of
omnipotence you've probably heard the
paradox of the stone before can God
create a stone that cannot be lifted if
God can create such a stone then he is
not then he is not all-powerful since he
himself cannot lift it on the other hand
if he cannot create a stone that cannot
be lifted then he is not all-powerful
since he cannot create the unlived Abul
stone either way God is not all-powerful
oh my this is awkward where this is a
philosophy professor and he's starting
he's coming right out of the gate his
first argument is the heavy stone thing
that's why starting with this I remind
you again is a philosophy professor and
he comes out the gate with a theological
conundrum that used to confuse me when I
was 6 years old I can remember being 6
years old and in having this discussion
with my parents about can God make a
rock so big he can't lift it as an adult
now I realize that this hypothetical is
nonsense it is a logical contradiction
for God who is all powerful all stones
by definition are liftable all-powerful
means you can do all things and so for
an all-powerful God that means that all
stones are inherently liftable so what
you're really asking is can God create a
liftable unlifted
stone and the answer obviously is no
that's an easy answer easy question
answer no he can't do that
does that prove that he's not
all-powerful no because it's in the same
sense that he can't create a square
circle he can't exist and not exist at
the same time he can't make north south
and south north he can't make chili with
beans in it these are logical
contradictions if a thing has four sides
it's not a circle if a thing has beans
in it it's not a chili that's that's
that's just the way that it goes so this
question is is nonsense you may as well
disprove God by saying can God bloobity
blue well no he can't be liberty blue
because that doesn't mean anything he
continues a little later on he says
let's see can God create a world in
which evil does not exist this does
appear to be logically possible
presumably God could have created such a
world without contradiction it evidently
would it would be a world very different
from the one we currently inhabit but a
possible world all the same if indeed if
God is morally perfect it is difficult
to see why he wouldn't have created such
a world that is a perfect world why so
why didn't he the standard defense is
that all that evil is necessary for free
will well not exactly we'll get to that
a minute according to the well-known
Christian philosopher Alvin Plantinga to
create creatures capable of moral good
God must create creatures capable of
moral evil and he can't give these
creatures the freedom to perform evil
and at the same time prevent them from
doing so however this does not explain
so-called physical evil suffering caused
by non-human causes like famines
earthquakes etc nor does it explain as
Charles Darwin noted why there should be
so much pain and suffering among the
animal kingdom okay so the problem of
evil he goes from unlifted will stone
and then next he's going to the problem
of evil this can be separated into two
basic categories man caused evil and non
man caused evil or what we might call
natural evil the man caused evil really
presents no challenge whatsoever it it
now the evil it said that the suffering
itself is a challenge it's a it's a huge
challenge it's a it's a it's a
difficulty but in terms of in terms of a
theological challenge there isn't much
there if we are as as alvin plantinga
noted if we are to have free will then
we must have the ability to do good or
bad just as if we are to have the
freedom to go north then we also have to
have the freedom to go south if North is
the only option then we can't say that
we had the freedom to go north we had no
other choice so this to me seems rather
obvious although he opened that
paragraph
by saying well you know Christians will
claim that evil is necessary in order
for good to exist that's not exactly
true that's not what we're saying we're
saying that the possibility of evil is
necessary in order for good to exist
it's not that that the good is reliance
on the evil or something like that it's
this isn't some sort of dualist notion
it's just that if you're going to give
people freedom then in that freedom
there must be at least the potential for
them to do a bad thing or else it's not
freedom and if you're forcing someone if
you're compelling them to always make
the right choice to always do the good
thing to be loving to be patient to be
kind well then it's not really them
being those things then it would really
be god then we're all marionettes on a
string and God is just up there making
us dance around and life becomes
meaningless so that to me seems rather
obvious what about non man-caused evil
the press the professor mentions famines
and earthquakes well let's leave aside
that freewill actually does play a part
in some of those things famines are
often caused by incompetence and
governments such as in North Korea and
other kinds of human failures can cause
famines but not always and certainly
earthquakes aren't caused by people
there are many kinds of suffering that
are not directly caused by human action
yet the judeo-christian view is that in
a way actually humans did cause those
things by rejecting God mankind fell
into discord with nature fell out of
balance and that harmony with with the
natural world was lost thus you have now
all these terrible things such as
famines and earthquakes and cancer and
everything else now you may not like
that answer but the point is that
someone brought up in the Judeo
judeo-christian tradition does have an
answer for that that problem it's not
like we have no answer for it what about
animal suffering again that discord that
disharmony plays a part in that I think
also we should remember that we don't
really know to what extent animals
experience pain now we know that they
feel pain they're capable of paying
they have nervous systems but we don't
know to what extent they they are
conscious of the fact that they are in
pain can a dog say to himself I am in
pain does that it does a god does a dog
have I concepts in that way well that's
that's a difficult question
and it's one that the professor
certainly doesn't try to answer okay
then he says what about God's infinite
knowledge his omniscience if God knows
knows all there is to know then he knows
at least as much as we know but if he
knows what we know then this would
appear to detract from his perfection
why there are some things we know that
if they were also known to God would
automatically make him a sinner which of
course is in contradiction with the
concept of God as the late American
philosopher Michael Martin has already
pointed out if God knows all that is
knowable then God must know things that
we do like lust and envy but one cannot
know lust and no Envy unless one has
experienced them but they've had
feelings of lust and envy is to have
sinned in which case God cannot be
morally perfect all right this is kind
of bizarre he's arguing here that God
would need to be sinful in order to know
everything but although philosophy is
the love of knowledge this philosophy
professor has ironically a fundamental
misunderstanding about the nature of
knowledge an emotional experience is not
knowledge God is well aware that
sadistic people lustful people exist he
doesn't actually need to be sadistic in
order to have the knowledge of and about
this fact you might as well claim that
God is an omniscient because he's never
had a toothache it just it doesn't make
any sense and by the way you've also
you've also basically with this argument
discarded all of psychiatry psychology
all of that because then you're telling
us that well you know unless you've
actually been a sociopath unless you've
been a psychopath unless you've
you know unless you've been
schizophrenic you can't really know
anything about it this is sort of a
similar argument to the one that a kid
in Sunday school might might pose to his
teacher to try to stump his teacher if
God is all-powerful then Kenny sin can
he tell a lie and if he can't sin then
he must not be all-powerful and if he
can and he's not morally perfect right
but this is a misunderstanding of power
a sin is not an act of power it's an
it's a lack of power it's an act of
weakness a person sins because they have
no control over their impulses and their
desires an all-powerful person would by
necessity be sinless so when we say that
God is all-powerful all-knowing when we
say all-powerful we mean that he is
literally all power he has only power he
has no weakness if you want to put it
that way which means that yes he he
cannot be weak but that is not that
doesn't mean that he's not all-powerful
you see it just doesn't make any sense
you're saying if God is not weak than he
if God can't be weak that it can't be
powerful what in a similar way people
who give in to lust or sadism or
whatever else they are not gaining
knowledge in doing this they are in fact
demonstrating a lack of knowledge
they're demonstrating a lack of
understanding a lack of wisdom remember
part of our part of omniscience is is
knowing everything that will happen well
if you could see in real time the
negative consequences of your bad
actions then you would probably be less
tempted to do them right if a man could
actually see in real time before he
commits adultery let's say let's say if
he could see his marriage being
destroyed his kids being traumatized his
whole life falling apart if he could
really see that not just kind of know
about it in the abstract as a
possibility but see it happening then I
think he would be not so tempted anymore
to to commit the adultery so you see
we're perfect knowledge and perfect
wisdom will mean that you're not going
to be tempted to these things
and that's basically the end of the
article that's it I mean that's the
whole that's the whole argument against
God I would say that it fails amazingly
he never even makes the best logical
arguments against God I'm a theist and I
could have done a better job than him if
you're trying to find apparent logical
contradictions between God's various
attributes your best bet is to look at
omnipotence and emissions okay
you could try to argue that omnipotence
cannot coexist with omniscience so
omniscience means you know everything
you're going to do in the future if you
do something other than what you knew
you would do you're not omniscient but
if you can't do anything other than what
you know you're going to do then you're
not omnipotent okay that is that is one
logical argument you could try to make
amazingly this philosophy professor
never makes that argument and that at
least is interesting where you're saying
well if you know everything you're going
to do and you're all-powerful then how
does that work because don't you have to
do the things you know you're going to
do which would seem to detract from your
your omnipotence so that net at least is
an interesting argument that out there
for the next person who wants to write
an article in The New York Times
although it that also fails because all
we have to do is point out the fact that
God is is eternal and if he's eternal
that means that he exists outside of
time we know that time is finite that
time came into existence at a specific
point along with space so it's a
dimension of reality and if God is the
creator of the world and that means he's
the creator of that dimension which
means that he exists outside of time
which means that for God it's not as
though he knows what he's going to do
like he's looking in a crystal ball and
he can see the future for him everything
is now so there is no what he's going to
do there's no what he did it's just all
now now how does that work how can a how
what does it mean to be in
eternal now I don't know exactly
obviously I can't wrap my head around it
but that is the concept of God that
people who are part of the
judeo-christian tradition are working
with and if you're going to argue
against God or at least against the
judeo-christian God then you have to
engage with those points all right
finally I'm gonna skip emails for today
because I need to touch on this
that was unfortunate phrasing actually I
guess because the subject is men's only
cuddling groups the daily wire reports a
Plymouth Pennsylvania men's group is
introducing an all men's cuddling event
in order to help men redefine
masculinity in their own lives and to
cope with past sexual abuse the men's
therapeutic cuddle group as it's known
on meetup.com wants to help all men and
aims to provide a safe structured and
platonic environment for men to
experience the three A's acceptance
affirmation and affection let's see you
have to be 18 years or older you have to
be hygienic lee sound whatever that
means I guess that's just a polite way
of telling someone they have Bo or
something's that hey man you're not very
hygienic Lee sound right now more
details from the blaze it says group
organizer suggests holding your fellow
man motorcycle style which is described
as if you're taking notes on this it's
described as the holder who sits on a
pillow on the floor with his back
against a wall or sofa and the second
man the one being held sits in front of
the holder facing forward so his back
rests on the holders chest his head on
the shoulder the holder will embrace the
man around the chest and in time may be
asked for additional forms of affection
such as hand-holding hair or beard
stroking back rubbing and hand massages
other options reportedly include
spooning and the cuddle train now
unfortunately there is no explanation or
description provide provided for the
cuddle train but I
we can if we want to imagine it here's
the good news the event is in April and
you can still sign up for it fellas if
you want to there's plenty of space
available although there won't be a lot
of space on the cuddle train so don't
miss out on your chance to be groped by
strange men so I guess the point here is
one to combat toxic masculinity which
yeah mission accomplished
you have utterly obliterated masculinity
so that that you've done goal achieved
and then also though it's they're trying
to help heal sexual abuse well that's
kind of strange because it seems to me
that sexual predators might be exactly
the sorts of people attracted to an
event like this right so basically what
they're saying is come out and put
yourself in a position to be sexually
abused again in order to heal from
sexual abuse that strikes me as a bit
deranged the whole thing does really
listen if you're if you're looking for
some male bonding it just go to the bar
have a pint you know play some pool or
something you know I think I think
cuddling maybe takes it a step or two
too far but then what do I know because
I am someone who is who has been I like
to think plagued by toxic masculinity
after all you know look at my beard
which has never been stroked by a man
which apparently is one of the options
at the cuddle group all right we will
leave it there on that very awkward note
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Knowles show Cook County prosecutors
abruptly and bewildering Lee drop all
charges against hate crime hoaxes are
Jesse Smollett who now like OJ will no
doubt go on the hunt for the real
attackers check it out at daily wire com